consider the polynomials P of X is equal
to X to the 6 minus X to the fifth minus
X to the third minus x squared minus X
and Q of X is equal to X to the fourth
minus X to the third minus x squared
minus 1 given that Z 1 Z 2 and Z Z 3 and
Z 4 are the roots of Q of x equals 0
find P of Z 1 plus P of Z 2 plus P of Z
3 plus P of Z 4 so a good place to start
and Union this you might have already
realized this and if these guys are the
roots of Q of x equals 0 that means that
Q of Z 1 is equal to Q of Z 2 which is
equal to Q of Z 3 which is equal to Q of
Z 4 which is equal to 0 there the roots
there are solutions to this equation
here now given that and we want to
evaluate P of Z 1 plus P of Z 2 it seems
like it would be useful if we can
express P of X in terms of Q of X
because then when we evaluate these the
parts that would be Q of Z 1 or Z 2 or
whatever would evaluate to 0 so let's
try to do that over there so the first
thing I'm going to try to do I'm going
to try to get Express these higher
degree terms in terms of Q of X and to
do that
if I multiply Q of x times x squared
this X to the 4th will become an X to
the 6 this X to the 3rd we would come an
X to the fifth it won't be exact but we
might be able to adjust it a little bit
to get something right over here so
let's try to do that so let's think a
little bit about what let's think about
what x squared x squared times Q of X is
going to look like that's going to be x
squared times X to the fourth that's X
to the sixth minus X to the fifth minus
X to the fourth minus x squared just
multiply it all of these terms times x
squared now that isn't exactly what we
have up here for P of X in order to get
it exact in order to get it exact
we need to what are we going to have to
do let's see we don't have an X to the
fourth up here so we have to get rid of
this X to the fourth so let's add X to
the fourth to both sides so let's add X
to the fourth to both sides of this
equation so that would get rid of an X
to the fourth and let's see we have No
to the third here we do have an X to the
third there so let's subtract X to the
third from both sides of this equation
so I'm going to subtract X to the third
from both sides of this equation and
then we do have a negative x squared we
do have a negative x squared over here
and then we have a negative x here I
don't see a negative x over here so
let's subtract a negative x from both
sides so negative X this is all for the
left-hand side and so we are left with
the left-hand side of the equation we
get x squared times Q of X x squared
times Q of X plus X to the fourth plus X
to the fourth minus X third minus X is
equal to what's this equal to it's equal
to X to the sixth I didn't want to use
that shade of purple let me use the blue
one it's equal to X to the sixth minus X
to the fifth these guys cancel out minus
X to the third minus X to the third
minus x squared minus x squared and then
you have a minus X there minus X which
is exactly this is we were actually able
to completely construct P of X this is
equal to P of X it's equal to all of
this business on the left hand side now
we could just stop there but it looks
this part right here this part right
here looks tantalizingly close to Q of X
as well in fact it is that part right
there using the exact same process would
be Q of X just the green part it's Q of
X what these things gotten rid of so we
would have to add an x squared so it's Q
of X plus x squared plus x squared plus
one right if you start with Q of X you
add an x squared out of one these two
will go away you just have an X to the
fourth minus X to the third so now we
can rewrite P of X we can rewrite P of X
I'll do it right over here P of X is
equal to x squared times Q of X these
people do know that's not the same blue
it's equal to x squared times Q of X
plus this business plus Q of X
plus x squared plus one and then we have
this last negative X or last minus X
right over there
now when we evaluate if I say if I say
that R is a root R so if R is a root of
Q or if I write Q of R is equal to zero
then what is P of R P of R is going to
be equal to x squared times Q of R plus
Q of R plus R squared I'll switch these
minus R plus 1 so this is going to be 0
obviously Q of R is 0 so this whole term
is 0 this whole term is 0 so P of R is
going to be equal to R squared minus R
plus 1 now obviously all of these guys
are roots so we can use that same logic
we can use that same logic we can say P
of let me do a new color here a new
color is warranted P of Z 1 is equal to
Z 1 squared minus Z 1 plus 1 P of Z 2 P
of Z 2 is equal to Z 2 squared minus Z 2
plus 1 I could I'll go all for P of Z 3
P of Z 3 is equal to Z 3 squared minus Z
3 plus 1 and then finally we have P of Z
for P of Z 4 in a slightly different
shade of orange is Z sub 4 squared minus
Z sub 4 plus 1 now remember our problem
we just want to find the sum of these
things we just want to take we just want
to take the sum so this sum is going to
be the sum of these expressions and you
might be saying Sal we still don't know
what these sums are I could sum all the
ones I'll get a 4 there but not have to
sum all the roots of Q of X and have to
sum all the squares of the roots of Q of
X and this is not a simple thing and
frankly it's not taught in most algebra
classes or precalculus classes this is a
problem to really separate the people
who study who study kind of quirky
properties of polynomials from the
people who don't study quirky properties
polynomials but the last two videos I
just recorded in the competition math
playlist and actually added them to the
algebra playlist as well tell you how to
find the sum of the roots of a
polynomial or the sum of the squares of
the roots of a polynomial so let's think
about this a little bit so let's add up
all the ones that's easy we get four now
we're also going to have to add up all
of when you add up all of these guys
over here let me do this in a new color
when I add up all of these guys over
here it's going to be negative Z 1 plus
Z 2 plus Z 3 plus Z 4 now two videos ago
I think it was we show that the sum of
the roots of a polynomial and this is
the sum of the roots of Q of X that that
is equal to the negative of the
coefficient on the second to highest
degree term or I should say that on the
degree term that's one less than the
highest degree term so if we go to Q of
X we go to Q of X it's a fourth degree
polynomial the sum of the roots to find
the sum of the roots we go one degree
less than that so we look for the third
degree term that's this over here the
coefficient on the third degree term
over here is negative one it has a
negative one coefficient so the sum of
the roots the sum of the roots this over
here is going to be called the negative
of that coefficient so negative negative
one so it's the negative of negative 1
which is just +1 and of course we have a
negative out front here so this whole
thing is going to evaluate to negative
one so that whole business evaluates to
negative one now we have to take the sum
of the squares we have to do all of this
over here we have to do all of this over
here the sum of Z 1 squared plus Z 2
squared plus Z 3 squared plus Z 4
squared now in the last video where I
talked about the sum of this question I
didn't prove it for the fourth degree
case it's actually pretty easy to extend
it from the third degree case we did in
that video to the fourth degree and it's
a little messy to do it generally do the
in to hold induction thing that I did
with the straight up so I'm not the sum
of the squares but hopefully you see the
the or at least you understood how to
apply it and if you're interested you
actually could extend it to the fourth
power to the nth power but this is going
to be equal to
the coefficient on I should look at Q of
X the coefficient on the degree 1 less
than the highest degree so it's going to
be so this is the negative 1 so it's
going to be equal to negative 1 squared
negative 1 squared minus 2 times the
coefficient on the degree below that so
minus 2 times the coefficient over here
so over here so we're we're looking we
started at this degree
now we're going even one lower than that
to lower than the degree of the
polynomial so go to the x squared term
this coefficient is negative 1 so minus
2 times negative 1 this is equal to 1 1
plus 2 which is equal to 3 so this thing
over here in green when you take the sum
of the squares it's equal to 3 and so
when you take the total sum of P
evaluated at each of those pop possibly
complex numbers we get 3 minus 2 plus 4
is equal to 6 and we're done